[Musique]
ta peau contre ma ta peau contre ma peau
laisse à penser le ser soler soit urbain
bangr de rouler à l'e10 alors les walker
soulas je vais prendre la solution de
les voir faire longtemps toutes les
longs espagnols tsl coming of el qods
s'appelle t on à rafa nadal quelle
hausse comme à la bien là le tgv de
l'amour
attention attention cinq minutes dans et
venez vous éloigner de la bourse us
on est train desservira et vous avez
remarqué au pas dans les traces j'adore
il ya toujours est ailleurs google ou m
3 minutes et trendy servir à l'égard de
philo sur bilou iard et bien sûr faire
un arrêt assez le parc russes blancs
tout va ouvrir ou togoudo tchekhov à
tous
après le confinement
je vous le dire comme je le pensais je
veux que français il ya bien un secteur
qui connaît pas la crise avec le
confinement je vous dire c'est lequel
eh ben je voulais dire c'est celui des
sites et des applications de rencontre
pourquoi je vous le dire moi j'ai pas
connu car l'assurance-vie j'aurais très
bien pu quant à kaka et atout france
prenez mes gosses est ma télé [ __ ] de
pigeons d'un pigeon je te dis la vérité
crue excuse moi je t'aime beaucoup
mettez leur sert il j'ai décidé de faire
un petit blind test pour me tester et
oui j'ai envie de savoir si je suis dans
des fraudes à bout pas dans les gênes
sur les génériques de séries de télé ou
de jeter les incendies
avant de former la paire louis
[Musique]
dans secret story je connais pas c'est
l'émission je regardais jamais je
détestais je laisserai l'animateur
[Rires]
[Musique]
j'adore j'adore côte ouest
t'es pas là ce mélange de mensonges les
passions hu le long du grand pacifique
des vagues défie le temps en tout cas ya
une lune qui ne bouge jamais c'est bien
celle de benjamin castaldi horoya
[Musique]
oh ça c'est quoi ton monte les escaliers
parce que passe partout il est longtemps
restée options boîte à musique côté papa
noël oui noël quand tu descendras du
ciel avec chouchou parmi la vdab la
benhaim longtemps jeté garder comme le
père le rav l'âge et naïve mais c'est
toi qui m'a aidé à larguer les hallaba
quand le soleil sous le soleil en face
ils jamais facile ce salaire et marie
les deux
et jouer pareil jusqu'à en oublier tout
fermer les yeux
c'est le même bleu
[Musique]